[Musique]
et donc c'est un succès c'est un
aboutissement c'est un immense espoir
qui s'ouvre pour des dizaines de
milliers de patientes mais le l'intérêt
de cette recherche n'est pas uniquement
dans la naissance mais aussi don à
toutes les avancées autour de cet hymne
et thématiques qui est la
transplantation et terry
[Musique]
deborah bénéficié de la greffe d'utérus
il avait 34 ans actuellement la 35 ans
et quelques mois
là c'est elle a un désir d'une deuxième
grossesse nous allons évaluer l'état de
l'utérus l'état de la patiente le risque
de complications pour la suite pour
autoriser ou non sa deuxième vingt
deuxième grossesse et si tout se passe
bien normalement adoré avoir une
deuxième grossesse dont au bout d'un an
ou deux selon ce qu'elle désire
[Musique]
inquiet de vous dire qu'elle est
heureuse bien sûr elle est heureuse et
se passe bien il n'y a pas de
complication à la récupérer à la halle
est elle s'occupait sa petite donc tout
se passe très bien
[Musique]